I want to jump to the store we got from
timcast.com
bidenpardon's federal convictions for
low-level marijuana possession today we
begin to write these wrongs Biden said
the pardon also applies to lawful
permanent residents who have been
charged with simple possession as well
as individuals who have been charged but
not yet stood trial quote as I've said
before no one should be in jail just for
using or possessing marijuana today I'm
taking steps to end our failed approach
allow me to lay them out okay uh I agree
with this I said Trump should have done
the same thing I don't like Joe Biden
and this earns no brownie points as far
as I'm concerned because I think this is
just pandering I I I but I still look
respect for uh credit credit where
credit is due I think they should have
been doing this a long time ago I think
Donald Trump should have done it I don't
trust Biden actually do anything I don't
think Democrats are actually going to
you know take marijuana off schedule one
but what do you guys think
do we know how many people this
represents
I mean are we talking about thousands
millions I think it's thousands I have
seen that at the federal level right now
there are zero that's what I heard I
didn't check it out I didn't check it
out for this minor thing that they're
they're classing it under what is a
simple possession there's no one which
would be really interesting I did see a
meme earlier so this could just be a
publicity stunt though oh yeah it sure
could be I mean I saw a meme earlier
today about Kamala Harris looking
through the blinds very sadly as Joe
Biden releases all the people's shoes so
carefully putting in jail for marijuana
possessions I kind of lower Camelot I
like the way this sounds though I
haven't looked into it yet it's similar
to that AI Bill of Rights that they
proposed a few days ago I think that
even an incompetent government can get
stuff right and you know no one's pure
evil or pure good so in a way I mean
definitely we should make marijuana not
schedule one narcotic completely insane
it's a plant it's like an herb yeah just
don't ever use the thing it's freaking
drug it's potent you know the War on
Drugs is a farce that just abuses people
that have substance abuse problems that
are never dealt with and only made worse
and people are made harder criminals and
bigger criminals just by going into our
Penitentiary system so I think they're
they're reaching in a bag they're like
holy cow we screwed these people over
really bad we we robbed them of all
their money we robbed them of of energy
we robbed them of any kind of potential
let's just give them a little crumb here
and let's hope that affects the upcoming
elections because I think they are
desperate I think the the War on Drugs
just like the war on terror is is just
manufactured to control populations it's
it's good to see a portion of it stop
but will this actually have real effect
again I'm skeptical so yeah he's saying
that he's calling on the uh attorney
general to initiate a process of
reviewing how marijuana is scheduled
under federal law because it's
considered more serious than fentanyl
which is just insane so crazy yep
why didn't Trump do it though
good question
I guess why why why
I don't know if I say he was going to do
it before the the split between the
traditional conservatives who do vote
for him and the Maga types who are more
libertarian he thought he wouldn't get
realized I think yeah I think it would
have potentially split his base and and
been harmful to him he might not have
won if he didn't do it oh wait he didn't
I don't think it would have been harmful
to him at all I think there would have
been some people who would have been
like I don't think he's right to do but
there's no way I'm voting for Biden you
know let the states decide jeez like do
you think any Trump supporter is going
to vote for Joe Biden for doing this
no no he's got to earn my respect in
many many ways more than one or two
moves the student loan thing for
instance all of a sudden he went back on
it they were gonna give ten thousand
dollars everyone that has a loan and
then it turns out not if you have a
private loan only if you had government
loans only sorry and there's so many
people with private loans that aren't
getting them oh they're gonna walk the
whole thing back of course yeah it's
gonna be like the day before the
election is gonna be like oh yeah how
about that but like crumpled up and
throw it in the garden there was no
public and I didn't see like a public
press conference about not doing it they
just quietly were like that's what all
this stuff is he's just throwing stuff
against the wall he's going to keep
doing that until election day it's
because he can't do it anyway he's got
nothing else this is why we have this
weird pseudo War you know with Russia
because they're not allowed to do it Joe
Biden doesn't have the authority to
forgive student loans so naturally
within a month or a few months they're
like oh yeah he's not actually doing
that like imagine if Joe Biden came I
was like I'm gonna give everybody who
votes for me a thousand dollars
he can't so it's like you he's lying you
know people believe it I guess that's
government though right
what else is new half the time at least
I'm really that's generous it's a lot of
like projections about what they're
calling I mean are you kidding me I just
I just finally
don't say like we're going to fill in
the blank and like yeah you didn't do it
yet wait do it and then tell me you did
it then that at least isn't alive well
it's like Lydia was saying there might
not even be a single person I just
pulled it up I don't know if this is
correct but I'm hearing that 99 of
federal drug offenders are sentenced for
trafficking uh I haven't fact checked
this so someone could fact check this
and that only 92 people were sentenced
for marijuana possession in the federal
system in 2017 out of nearly 20 000 uh
drug convictions so um yeah it's like if
Joe Biden came out and was like all
those you know children who are
negatively impacted by the Alien
Invasion will receive a million dollars
from the government you're like okay
that's zero it's like hey hey we're
helping kids hey man right kept that
promise because people will hear this
this is brilliant man you know in terms
of manipul relating people this is just
so good
announcing that you're going to be
partying a tiny tiny group of people but
then saying there are thousands of
people who were previously convicted
convincing people that you actually did
a thing when there's no one that's for
the most part being affected now look to
those 92 people in 2017 or whatever I'm
sure there was a hundred and 2018 19 20
21 22. uh so we're looking at maybe you
know several hundred people I'm sure
their lives will be improved by this
hell yeah but he's not doing what I
suggested Trump do which was basically
pardon anybody for any crime relating to
any non-violent crime who didn't plead
down so that means if they had like
large possession or trafficking I don't
care yeah trafficking for references
when you have 25 kilograms or more or
300 or more plants of marijuana here's
what you do everybody who's been
convicted for that
if they didn't plead down from a violent
offense they should be they should have
to go through a mandatory licensing
process and then be released
that's it yeah
like you were you were trafficking all
of this Agricultural Product without a
permit so it's a 50 fine get your permit
have a nice day get rid of the permit
permitting system right away
I'm disgusted by that time I'm just
saying like the appropriate thing to do
is you know it's it's let people be and
if they're not hurting anyone if they're
just deciding to to smoke something or
put something in the right it's their
choice in their decision even though
they should be informed though that
there are extremely negative
consequences that we're not being told
when it comes to marijuana and marijuana
is becoming more potent it's becoming
more dangerous and does have negative
effects on some human beings so people
need to understand there's dangers in in
doing this but at the same time the
government coming in and throwing you in
jail for doing this is not going to
solve the problem I had some old uh old
hippies talking to me about how pot
today is nothing like it was in the 70s
like in the 70s it was weak and they
were like yeah so you'd smoke and it was
like you know now it's just like boom
it's very powerful stuff so so maybe you
know we got to be careful about all
drugs but you know look man my attitude
is if you want to go into your closet
and you know smoke
inject I don't know whatever as long as
you're not hurting other people
I I actually think that regulation is
the is the best way towards helping
people ending the Violence by pushing
into the black market you only create a
space for this so the appropriate thing
to do in my opinion is legalize with
restrictions if people if people are
addicted to opiates give them a space
where you can go and help them and make
sure they don't die from it yeah instead
they tell you well you might as well go
hide in a basement and then when you OD
too bad No One's Gonna call for help
because they're scared to go they're
scared when you can't get your
prescription filled you'll go down to
Skid Row to find somebody with fentanyl
you know when they run out of their
Oxycontin or whatever they look for
something else because they don't yeah
man but the thing about weed is it is
legal it's it's um it is legal I'm like
what am I okay let's go with it no it's
um addictive and you know mildly I think
physically definitely psychologically
addictive and giving it to kids is
messed up I Used to Know kids in high
school that I never smoked until I was
23 but like in high school they were
just slow and dull and like bored with
school and like maybe they were slowing
down to school anyway but they would be
more slow and more dull when they would
come into work smelling like pot and
like you know weren't mean or anything
we're just like I don't know yeah it
should be just like alcohol you know and
and you know marijuana does have some
medicinal properties but at the same
time there's also other forms of
marijuana that will absolutely knock you
on your butt and have very severe
negative consequences especially if
you're a child as a rewires your brain
and and predominantly does make a lot of
people lazy some people would actually
make some energized some people actually
gives them inspiration some people it
helps some people it hurts just like
anything in life lazy right yeah when I
when I went to Colorado I and I I took
for the first time I I remember having
this thought like holy cat it's kind of
dangerous for me because I I right now I
feel like I would be completely happy
never accomplishing anything ever again
everything's good right now it's a big
part of the transhumans agenda is put
you in the universe and Alex they just
want you sitting down
yeah I'm surprised the government's not
giving out free weed at this point I see
them doing this a couple years from now
being like yes get high just just
totally forget about everything just
just go on the couch they're gonna sit
there don't worry about anything there's
a nice pod next to that couch that we're
also going to give you next will be uh
what was the children of men remember
that movie when they were handing that
suicide kits to everybody these little
boxes yeah they're gonna they're gonna
try and create some kind of patentable
derivative that they can control the
price on then they're going to say
everybody needs this because it's
distresses and then they're gonna say
the government should pay for it
everybody gets taxed without realizing
it and then they're paying for the
thousand dollar pills it's Marinol it's
called Marinol and it's uh International
non-proprietary name is dronabinol also
known as Delta 9 Tetra
hydrocannabinol I guess they've they've
pharmaceuticalized it yeah Marinol
syndrome and adversa adversal whatever
you do it's great yeah whatever you do
do not smoke it's a challenge whatever
you do do not smoke the government weed
yeah whatever you do keep and free Luke
don't eat them it's gonna be insurance
is going to cover it what was that movie
Children of Men Children of Men yeah
we're we're closely approaching that
that future and that's if you haven't
watched that movie it's it's soon to be
a documentary did you see the videos out
of Canada where the guys like he calls
the hotline and they're like if you need
help dying let us know oh yeah yeah yeah
they're like pushing people to that yeah
well and we're almost seeing that a
little bit in the states too with
insurance companies that that will you
know they won't cover your your surgery
or their or your treatment but they will
cover you know your your uh whatever you
call it your death With Dignity you know
we'll give you painkillers until you die
let's there's kind of that movement just
scoop people along let's let's move it
along here wow and uh yeah you see it
you wanna you wanna know where we're
headed in 10 15 years look at Canada
look at Europe yeah that's where we're
headed ethics oversight over
pharmaceutical companies and insurance
companies I mean it's got to be like
governmental ethics that's a big part of
our government is ethics that's the
dudes that wrote the US Constitution
were ethicists they understood religious
and moral ethics and that's why there
were so many of them they didn't agree
on the Logics and the literals all the
time but they got like the ethics for
the most part you know the slavery thing
was still debatable at the time so I
feel like the founding fathers really
understood human nature which is
probably which what made them strong
ethicists and I think you're correct I
think the problem now is that I don't
think government ethics is ethical I
don't think it's ever a good idea for a
government ethics board to oversee
something like the pharmaceutical
company I think they're too tightly too
tightly combined I think it needs to be
an independent outside organization I
have seen Marinol used it was used to
stimulate appetite for an older lady who
was really struggling to eat so it does
have like good purposes but it's not
I'm from Colorado so I've seen what
marijuana does to people and people used
to tell me all the time oh I can cure
anything it cures cancer what are you
talking about you're just being a downer
I was like I have seen it change people
and I've had people tell me I wish I'd
never started marijuana or I wish I
hadn't started as young as I did it
changed my overall life experience
hugely negative but that said it should
not be illegal I could say I missed a
lot of opportunities because I was
stoned but that's blaming the weed it
was my own fault like I had a good final
decision I could have went video games
it could have been alcohol you know
human beings find something yeah yeah
but it was me I I made the choice not to
go do the things that I feel like I
missed out on it wasn't and I blamed the
weed for years and stressed my family
out about it and then they started
freaking out about weed it wasn't the
weed it was me it was my own personal
lazy choice
so you got to make sure that whatever's
giving you that dopamine hit it's a it's
a positive thing with the with the
future I think South Park said it well
when um it's like they're they're
talking to the kids about their future
selves like they hire this company that
sends in fake versions of them from the
future who are like hey guys they're
smoking weed and then I became a loser
and then I finally at the end of Randy's
like son you know there's nothing really
bad about smoking pot other than it
makes you okay with being bored and then
when you're older you'll find that
you're not good at anything thanks for
checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
Monday through Friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the timcast IRL podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there